Alright, here we go
I've noticed something when people play this game
They never have enough water
They never have food
They never had water
That's what I wanna be
I wanna be STAN
This city has a thirst
and Stan the water man
is gonna ... is gonna bring
water to the people of this city that need it
I'm gonna make sure that people are hydrated
Properly maintain another hydration
I'm gonna be the water man!!!!
Ohh... What? hahahaha
Oh shit
Whaaat? hahah
Wait, hang on, I gotta get in the immersion of it
Hang on, we gotta immerse
Ah
Now that's immersion
Everybody say Hi to Stan
Stan the water man
Here with the plan
To make sure that this city gets all the water it needs
I gotta go to the job center because I need to get a job first
I'm thinking that for Stan
Stan the delivery man
It's gonna be
It's gonna be the one
Oh yeah
*I've noticed something about this city*
*I've noticed*
*Out there*
*Down there*
*Even down there*
*A severe lack of water*
*I know this*
*I know this city needs water more than anything else*
*If there's one thing that I've been put on this goddamn earth to do*
*It's to provide a thirst*
Sir!
Doing the Lord's work
I see you with that cup in there
Yeah, drink up
Yeah, that's good
That's good, you're gonna like that
You are gonna thank yourself later
And I'm gonna thank you now
All right
Carry on
The light's red
Waits for no men
Gotta go!
Need to get a job
Gotta buy some water
To give to the people
That's what the city needs
There's a disease
Lurking deep
Deep beneath here, and i'm gonna root it out
Stan, Stan, Stan, new to this city
But you are gonna make a difference
Hey!
Whatever
I´ll let him go
He was probably thirsty
Alright I just gotta find myself a job
Maybe as a delivery man
Maybe
Maybe that´s it
Maybe Stan the delivery man
Yeah
Stan the delivery man
Delivering water
Hello
Hello there
Are you thirsty?
Hi
Well, well, well...
Aren't you just beautiful
Look at you
Look. At. You. Go!
Wow
That is a slice of something special
Oh
Don't mind me Sir. I am not weird
Just looking at a cat
Lara di Lara di~
Oh chezz, oh God!, oooh don't! Oh God don't
Sorry
I panicked
Are you alright?
Alright, ehhh
Alright, ehem. Better get on the road here
Ufff
All set my first running
Not paying attention to where i'm going
Silly me, silly me
Alright
Here we go, job center
That's what I need
T-AHHHHHHHH AH AHHH
AHHHHHH   OOOOHH MYGOOOOD
Oh
Let's try this again
'H'... oh I'm getting a mental image
Hang on there
Alright
Delivery job
Entertainer!
Ohhh
Some people have said that I'm rather entertaining
So...ehm... maybe that could do me
Good old Stan the entertainer man
Yeah... probably not..
Alright, maybe not, I'll probably just go for the delivery job
I think that's exactly what I got going for me
That's my best quality, so...
Yeah, let's try to do that! Oh okay
Alright here we go
And ehh boop!
I got a delivery job!
Hello?!
Anybody?
Hello? Uhh
Ohh
Ohh Hi
Oh Excuse me
Ohhhh!!!!
Uh, UH OHH AHHH!
DEMONS!
AHHHHH!!!!
THIS PLACE IS HAUNTED!!
HOW DO I GET OUT OF HERE?!
THERE IS NO DOOR!!
The elevator?
It doesn't seem to work
Oh God
I can't escape!
THERE'S NO WAY!
OH!, oh, wait...
Door, the door was here the hole time
oh
I see
There! I got myself I job, a J. O. B. job
Now all that I gotta do is find out what that job means
suupeermarkeee  *French accent(?)*
Probably French
Alright, so
I need to get myself a van and I need to get myself a plan
And then I need to take Stand the man and get the water
So I can  get the water to the people
Ammuneacion *French accent(?)*
Ehhh, This place must be French
Alright, *I'm gonna find some kind of a person that could tell me*
*What exactly a delivery job entails*
*Excuse me!*
*Sorry! I shouted in my head instead of out of my mind*
*There's gonna be someone that knows something about delivery jobs*
*There's no one at the Job Center except the ghosts*
*All I know is this Town has a thirst and I got a purpose in life*
Oh! Oh I see!
Wow okaaay
All right, delivered to Mat Wayne Thunder Drive
Delivery to North Sheldon Drive
Delivery to South Moe Milton Drive
Delivery to Mr....
hmm, These are some complex deliveries
I'll figure out later I suppose
Oh, well, Whatever,
Doesn't matter to me, gotta go to the B-A-N-K, bank.
Gotta go see if I have any C-A-S-H, cash
yeah, maybe D-O-S-H, dosh
Well maybe if I pick up some, maybe then I can help out this city
but until then, I'm just a small fry, with a small bank account